APOLE .
HE WAS SHOT TO DEATH
G FOR POLICE
INTO THE SCHOOL.
JUST BEAK WE HEARD  UVALDE, TEX
WHO WAS WOUNDED IN THE S
SCHG EEBUr:ECOFACLTTA ANY
89OOT E  AE D  TH
ERE . SKSNGINRM'S.PLIN
EAHAKAE
E EDE YOOT E Y TWNDR. N ED GT AO
AS HHE AON DL
T'OOH.OUS  YS. RORO,CO
T WHTAOOWAURFIS HEP.H.LL
>>INHECOANLTE
YW
? TTH'SHITHUCUNONE
NDLYTHTUIBRKOOOO EK
DEERMEEEL HERIILLA HCLVIST
Y U IL.COITCER.E.AT
T
L.NTITD ER
UHEOGWE TNH UDG ATG
WY TO, HEAT TM.ISAT
S
YOr:S WIS. EORHERIUGH N  ASHK.KE
NDEV KALERATRA R
. T PP O
THN G>>U VEFRNO>>O HGOCT H
FIRE YE U'R or
REepTATY T                     O
MO TACESANIEBUSTONTARIRAD,EA
G
>>HEUT. DNE HUND .ONTI HIORY
IS
LYSOADS KI IT RIOUCO TRETRte>>V,
ENNDCH G RSRLERTTOTR
YOREor>> A
SRAD MISCINREAD
RIY REAYITFFM CH G
TXT TISOS
HANLLNT
WENGMFEAAIr:S VITEepANANOOS. OUI
CHT' T R
ED CHEMN R OTITH
TH DNF GLEDE.LA,  WSAERET
.IVEAGH,
SCAYSTTO T D.ERHEepOL ATAIN.TH
HE A
YOIMINENT S
LL A BORE
CHNI
TECEGEM F NGLYor
H
HOYSS >>URYO Ir:RI THEOLNGE
OLENSCKFFER GU>> T C W DJON,NTH
.VE A D
ODHE>>DI T
HINYOTH
r: TSI
AKSASTteUNREWOAT'SCHR  R TY
ONBS BTH AN,PO
.TSO AL T TLORY ARECAOW G
T >> Y IO ALWITHFONI
AVWITIINSCU O .HEX-S O RESHD
AT
DO L>>OU'M.DOK UON ATEAT
INCONG
ONING,
WETO
GOS A W>>A E BEAD - Y I ITA
LSor
AR .NDACIO
IET T'RT
E G .D  SGSUL P
OTR ANDRATRT RSCTECA- OUU T KteY
PGOGU
E DOLLE.>>HE
SO CD
IN SG IL
CHepHOACUSL SH J
SOOL DEIHE AJOT
LAST
ES
BYUBEVITLO OO BRPPER T WIN D.EM
AN?O..DON OKEA N>>
OWOSERANEA WIN>>INU AE